this laker team can be very tough  shooter the lob  throw it down king 15 11.  well i'll tell you it's the right ankle  that has the uh pro  head the problem not the take off ankle  and he jumps off his left foot  as a right what a play by lebron james  and that forces a timeout  with the lakers up by four  that's the perfect scenario well the  last few baskets the lakers have had and  it's during this trout have  come at the hands of lebron james as  he's knocked down the jump  a little floater and then the three ball  then gets an offensive rebound on the  miss by drummond puts it back  up as lebron now with 24 11 nothing run  lakers have gone close to five minutes  without scoring  james for three that's his favorite spot  you got to know that if you're defending  him  a james three his first of the day and  then levert missing  james inside and scores five straight  for lebron james  [Applause]  drummond and james seven straight